hey Justin hey Walt how's it going hey
doing just magically appeared here
you're like the in this pants gnome of
gamespot com and I also live in the
couch yeah just pop out just nail what
is here we're going to do some news
you've got a bunch of a bunch of a news
that came out yesterday news the came
out today well yeah Mary talking about
all the the upcoming games I'm here to
talk about some games that are not going
to be upcoming at least in the near near
future so some news that broke today the
witcher 3 is getting a slight delay i
know a lot of us have been really
excited to play which raphy of the Wild
Hunt and it was supposed to come out
this fall and it's been pushed a little
bit and which is not necessarily a bad
thing it's gonna be coming out februari
2015 and you know a delay like this
which is kind of later in the cycle but
with a pretty good tale behind it can I
just mean that they're polishing it I
mean I mean it's not a that the game is
going to be bad or that there's a
serious problem with it and this could
really be just an issue where they're
gonna polisher they're going to make the
game better and it's just part of the
schedule where they knew they weren't
going to hit that that date for it to
come out in the fall probably just gotta
like put a few more graphics in it right
probably some more sex more graphics oh
yeah definitely sex graphic because
there was a lot of sent graphic sex yeah
there was a jerk November slippage is
not you know uncommon but it sort of
tends to happen closer to the the times
livia slippage like that and I'll show
games companies thinking about other
games that are coming out around that
time back sometimes like to get out of
the way of some of the big titles coming
out and this November is probably gonna
be pretty crowded with ps4 and xbox one
titles I can see wanting to maybe get a
little breathing room yeah and summary
and marcher feel like the the new
November and it used to be that January
was one because I remember was a burnout
paradise came out in two thousand eight
maybe and there was nothing after like
five weeks so when it came out everyone
was playing it and the same thing
happened with dead space the following
year so you could see what happened when
titanfall but now it's obviously a fair
game I mean titanfall in Dark Souls 2
today arge to the big most anticipated
games of the entire year but not all
delays are good news drive club which
was supposed to be a PlayStation 4
launch title has gone back to the
drawing board okay not something you
ever ever want to hear in with your
words yeah that is the exact world back
to the drawing board
and especially for a game that was
supposed to be a launch title it was
going to come out sometime in spring I
mean so this is basically last minute
like the they are out of time to say
anything else that's happening with the
game and instead of delaying it there
was no comment on whether it's going to
come out in 2015 yeah it's back to the
drawing board which essentially means
that whatever they were working on has
been destroyed like they've cancelled it
probably some key team members have left
is what my best guess would be I don't
have any inside knowledge and it's just
going to be a completely different game
if it happens at this point so following
in the tradition of first-party sony
racing games and this will come out of
years after its supposed to or initially
come at this is kind of funny because in
a way when people when this was coming
out when our first announced people were
talking about how you know I guess gran
turismo they sort of maybe Sony are
falling out of favor with the guise of
polyphony or whatnot and are you at all
surprised that this is happening
considering what little life showed of
the game seems to be previz and i'll
actually gameplay it was surprising that
we saw so much of this game it III
leading up to it like this was a game
that I I felt was going to come out but
it was way too crowded especially in
that the launch lineup of need for speed
Ford Gran Turismo is something that a
lot of people associate with Sony then
introducing this new franchise that we
don't know about a lot a lot about the
cars look really good and everything
that I've seen like looks nice but it's
not a game i think that does not a lot
of people's radars compared to forts and
need for speed and grant trees and
perhaps even the witcher another game i
think that it's interesting that they
say going back to the drawing board that
they're that candid in the press release
because a lot of the times though you're
like I don't like delayed delayed in
debt like I feel like they don't always
so heavily imply like oh we're going to
make a different game what is going back
to the drawing board any racing game
mean though I mean loi to reinvent
rinsing we're gonna go with triangular
wheels I think these circle wheels just
aren't working at all I don't know
reports poor driveclub on a poor Witcher
3 hopefully at e3 will have a bunch more
at new games getting announced it will
fill the gap in our lives that those
games have now left Justin hey well
thank you very much for coming on thanks
for having me on
you